if you think mainstream media is behind  the explosion of delta case infections  uh and hospitalizations and deaths  how are we going to be able to have an  even remotely substantive conversation  with you we're not going to be able to  so then what do we have to do  we probably have to do what some cities  and states or mostly cities are starting  to do you want to go to the movies you  got to be vaccinated  you want to go to a restaurant and sit  indoors you got to be vaccinated and  you've got to start making it more  annoying not to be vaccinated because if  you think mainstream media is behind the  rising cases and not the fact that we've  only fully vaccinated roughly half the  country  then it's going to be very hard to  convince you otherwise really really  difficult stuff